how about
dreams what is a dream yeah well i i
more and more i don't know if you're
paying attention to this there's now
it's become more acceptable in the
scientific community to do large-scale
studies of psychedelics for example and
there's a lot of connection
between psychedelics and dreams there's
very similar states there's
there's a lot our mind does when it
detaches itself from reality that it can
just explore a lot of different ideas
it's very possible that dreams is you're
traveling somewhere
and the same thing with psychedelics
you're traveling somewhere
in a different not traveling through
physical space it's the other dimensions
that
we're talking about you're traveling
some other through some other dimension
to meet some other creature
people talk with dmt that they meet some
elves i've never done
i i'd like to i don't know if there's a
safe
legal way to do it but uh they all talk
about meeting
elves and like creatures like entities
and like who are they what's
what is this is it because they're high
or it's because
they're actually meeting something and
maybe there's no difference i mean that
uh who knows exactly and that takes us
right back to us not being able to
really understand
how our mind works you know i work in
artificial intelligence
it's clear that we understand so little
about intelligence
some basic things about intelligence
just at the
at the very sort of basic uh first
principles
level we don't understand what it means
to to reason to think to
assimilate pieces of knowledge together
from
the from the basics to the complex we
don't understand it we don't understand
how the human mind does it
we don't understand how the human mind
is able to take incredible
waterfall of information and filter
cleanly
into just like clean you only see the
things that are important
and are able to jump together and be
able to reason about the world
and at the same time have moments of
like genius of creativity
like what what is that that also you
know people
writers talk about that that they're you
know they're almost like communicating
with the muse like where do ideas come
from
yeah this is the joe rogan philosophy
but but i i do know that
past civilization were a lot of them
were based on
shamanism and you know what i think it's
sad is
if someone drink alcohol and when he's
drunk he's going to commit
like create like like murders or
something we're going to blame the
person right
we're going to say that's his fault it's
not the fault of alcohol
however if someone does psychedelic or
any
things that is illegal and do something
crazy now we're going to
put the fault on on psychedelic you know
what i mean and
perhaps the person itself is the
the reason why you know he's been doing
these things you know what i mean
so yeah it's fascinating our like
society you know like in canada they
just
legalize marijuana oh yeah yeah
marijuana is illegal
but before that before they did it like
if you talk for example to my dad my dad
is
against it like because the whole
mentality is like
it's drug it's bad at that but drinking
a glass you know drinking a beer it's
fine
i mean what is you know what i mean what
is
good what is bad and i guess
eating chocolate could be bad as well
for your health or i mean i'm going to
the extreme now but
yeah what is good what is bad if you use
it for recreation you use it for an
experience for
to learn about yourself it's like
it said that the line is very tiny you
know there are some countries that
drugs are all legals you know what i
mean and i i don't know the
the the stats but i would it would be
interesting to know if
they have more crimes there than
other countries where it's more strict i
would i would be interesting to know
about that it's fascinate me you know
yeah and
i mean we humans kind of just come up
with the arbitrary lines of what's good
what's bad
that applies with drugs that applies
with anything uh
that applies with animals for example we
talked about carnivore diet
maybe the time we live in now will be
remembered for
the cruelty to animals for example
and i believe this the 21st century will
be remembered
for our cruelty to robots
that uh eventually there will be a civil
rights movement for robots
where the the ones who choose to be
conscious the ones who have
consciousness will
say we deserve rights too we deserve to
be treated with respect too
how about the people we put in jail
people put in jail i mean if i think in
the future we'll look back
and we'll think of ourselves being
stupid to
you know to put people in jail instead
of you know like
trying to fix the problem in in in
at the base you know of course now we're
or i guess it's our ignorance that
made it in a way that we cannot sort
sometimes understand what makes
uh sometimes a psychopath a psychopath
or a murder a murderer but
you know if we can pinpoint the problem
and take care of it before
you know what i mean or made it in the
way that we can reestablish
that person in the society you know who
knows you know what was the future is
old it's interesting we live in an
interesting time
you